welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and just when it
seemed like DC were finally getting back
on that feet after Joker it seems like
they're taking one step forward and two
steps back with reactions from the
October screening of Wonder Woman 1984
labeling it a disaster throughout this
video I'm gonna be going through
everything that we know about the plot
from the leaks and the reactions to it
from the screenings there will be heavy
spoilers here and whilst leaks like this
should always be taken with a pinch of
salt the plot which was originally
posted on reddit was taken down to you
to a DMCA so it looks like it could
indeed be true you have been warned
and with that out the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
video now let's get into Wonder Woman
1984 okay so the screening was
apparently held last month and after
patty Jenkins stated that she recently
had shown the film to some audiences it
doesn't sound like things are looking
good for the movie according to those
who got to see the film early 1984 is
goofy slow-paced and very very plot
heavy redditors who have apparently
watched the film said that it was very
camp as well do you not to only it's a
tease setting but also many of the plot
devices that the film uses they said
that the source of Maxwell Lords power
comes from a magic stone that grants
wishes but it has a monkey's paw effect
that gives them an added curse and
overall throughout the movie curses feed
Maxwell Lords power and this is how he
grows stronger and stronger we did hear
rumors about this a couple of months
back and it seems like a pretty basic
plot device which yeah magic stone so I
think they just needed to invent a way
of why could pose such a threat towards
a superhuman now this magic stone
apparently falls into the hands of
Wonder Woman who when touching it
according to the leaks accidentally
wishes Steve Trevor alive again now to
make matters worse his spirit possesses
another man and only Diana sees him as
Steve whereas everyone else sees him as
the real person that he is this is meant
to be a sincere moment in which Diana
gets to be back with it true love but
according to the audience you just feel
bad for the guy that Steve has suddenly
possessed this wish costs her some of
her in
ability as bullets and knives can now
hurt her which yeah I think this is the
point where the film starts to cave in
on itself to you to convolution as they
said that for the movie she mainly
relies on the lasso as that doesn't lose
its powers and it's the only thing that
she can use with magic
now contradicting all of the prior
movies the lasso also appears to have
gotten an upgrade it now has the ability
to fire off bolts of lightning which I
don't know why she didn't use them
against doomsday or Steppenwolf but yet
to me that's often a big problem with
prequels where stuff set in the past is
somehow better than when it's in the
future and yeah it's often a problem
that arises when movies jump about a
timeline
anyway Diana having lost her ability to
fly with the help of Steve goes after
Lord in her invisible jet according to
the leak she can now change stuff
invisible with the stone yeah don't ask
me but this does harken back to the
comic books now as for the film I'm not
sure how it will turn out with her
having an invisible plane and the leaked
images that we saw of it it did look
kind of goofy but hey movie magic and
all that maybe they used the stone to
make it so that the invisible jet didn't
look bad but in turn unleashed a
terrible curse that means this movie
will suck anyway the rock also gives
Kristen wigs character Barbara Mann
verba the power of cheater this allows
her to hurt people with her claws and
move really fast there's apparently a
scene where she goes into a gym some
guys are making fun of her and then she
bench presses a thousand pounds and this
really shows them up he sure got them
there great work I'm starting to think
that this movie was written in the 80s
as well anyway people at the screening
said that when she does eventually
become the cheetah and done so
traditional look that it looks like a
cat reject and has her bouncing about in
a pretty mediocre suit she ends up
becoming the villain and she just wants
to stop Diana from taking down Lord due
to the fact that if she does cheetah
will lose her powers this leads to a big
fight and during it Lord and does all of
his wishes by mistake and cheetahs
powers go away Steve goes away too but
that's not the end of the story and it's
said that the movie rips off the ending
of Michio black with Dianna agreeing to
go on a date with the guy that Steve
possessed as he doesn't remember
anything yeah
really really bad now like I said leaks
like this should always be taken lightly
but again the post was removed by reddit
in response to a copyright notice so
that could be a lot of weight here
personally this plot leak is really
disheartening and it seems like for
every foot that DC put forward with
Joker they put too back with Wonder
Woman and I'm guessing birds of prey cuz
yeah that movie does not look good
honestly I think it's time that they
kind of wind down the DCU a bit as Barr
Shazam
Wonder Woman and Aquaman these movies
have been pretty disappointing actually
really like Man of Steel and the
extended cut of Batman V Superman but
they were panned and there was clearly a
lot of studio interference that stopped
those movies from being what they should
have been I think if this flops and
birds of prey does as well then DC
should just completely scrap everything
start from the ground up again with this
new timeline with Joker the new Batman
movie which is apparently set in the 90s
and just go from there with the goodwill
of everyone we can't just forget this
ever happened
I'm using the magic stone I wish it all
away this just sounds like a real step
down and the plot is so simplest to get
points that it really seems like a
retread of things that we've seen done a
hundred times before 20 years ago comic
book movies have moved on so much in the
last decade and I can see why fans are
very disappointed with this as it sounds
like it's just taking very basic
elements and dragging them out
make-a-wish storylines can often be very
lazy ways to fix things in films and the
fact that they are going with that to
resurrect Steve Trevor
is really worrying to me I want to have
a make-a-wish foundation to Mary gaga
anyway there's so many better ways that
could have been done and this was
originally thought to be a trick by
Hades or one of the old ancient gods but
to hear that he's brought back with just
a wish is very poor in my opinion things
just being sorted by wishing them and
having a be careful what you wish for
message behind it has been done to death
and it's not really a plot motif that I
find all that interesting anymore
especially for a superhero movie so I'm
really hoping that they take the
feedback from the audience and fix this
the amount of reshoots that go on at the
moment in movies leave things open to be
changed over and over so yeah oh
that they would take some time out and
fix it that's the last wish joke I
promise the movie was originally moved
forward from its release date so if they
have to push it back then that's okay by
me I just want the best movie possible
so if it's delayed then that's better to
me than releasing it with what these
leaks say there might not be true but we
definitely know that screening happened
and we know that reddit removed the post
so it does seem like these things could
be legit now obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the leak and if you
agree with me or if you think are they
sound good you know you might want to
see a Wonder Woman movie like this
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please like it and
make sure you check out my breakdown of
the leaks of Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker which would be linked at the
end we go over the entire movie and it's
ending so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more you want to
come chat to me after the video then
make sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey or head over to my
discord server which would be linked in
the description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with all the
latest videos on the channel so
hopefully I see you over there very soon
we're also giving away a free copy of
the Marvel phase 3 part 1 box on blu-ray
which contains Civil War Doctor Strange
homecoming Ragnarok and more and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is like the video make sure that
you subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts and the Wonder Woman leaks
in the comment section below the one is
gonna be chosen on the 15th of November
and the set will be shipped out from the
ento ever gets the prize so best of luck
to everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
you